ces habitantes de varsovie vont devoir
attendre pour faire les soldes
les centres commerciaux mais aussi les
hôtels et stations de ski ferment leurs
portes à partir de ce lundi
plutôt épargné par la première vague de
la pandémie le pays a vu sa situation
sanitaire se dégrader depuis le début de
l'automne
les nouvelles mesures ont été annoncées
il ya une dizaine de jours avec une
entrée en vigueur après noël
jeannie la troisième vague et les
risques qu'elle engendre se concrétise
nous pouvons être sûrs que
malheureusement notre système de santé
ne saura ne efficace ni en mesure de
soigner tous les malades rapidement les
rassemblements de plus de cinq personnes
sont interdits y compris pour le soir du
nouvel an les personnes qui arrivent de
l'étranger par des transports collectifs
devront se soumettre à une mise à
l'isolément de dix jours pour ses
habitants de la capitale
seule la campagne de vaccination pourra
venir à bout du virus
si j'en ai la possibilité je me ferai
vacciner mais quand je vois les
comportements irresponsables dans notre
société
je suis pessimiste je voudrais me faire
vacciner mais je préfère donner ma place
à ceux qui en ont le plus besoin c'est à
dire les personnes âgées et le personnel
médical
bien sûr dès que ce sera mon tour je me
ferai vacciner
je trouve que chacun devra le faire
la pologne compte à ce jour plus de
27000 décès djoko vide dont 20000 ces
six dernières semaines